ah les états unis qui réaffirment leur
soutien à taïwan au lendemain de
l'incursion d'avions chinois dans
l'espace aérien de l'île la deuxième en
deux jours un soutien solide comme un
roc premières déclarations de
l'administration byden concernant taiwan
les etats unis ont mobilisé en parallèle
un porte avions en mer de chine
méridionale une zone disputée théâtre
d'une lutte d'influencé entre washington
et pékin les autres sujets de friction
ne manquent pas entre les deux
puissances
lesquin déclaré espérer un nouveau
départ dans les relations sino
américaines avec l'arrivée de joe biden
à la maison blanche
aujourd'hui lors du forum économique de
davos le président chinois xi jinping a
mis en garde contre une nouvelle guerre
froide
l'analyse d'antoine bondage chargé de
recherche à la fondation pour la
recherche stratégique
spécialiste de l'asie ce qui est clair
c'est que les tensions systémique entre
la chine et les hadji ne cesse de se
renforcer
et encore une fois l'arrivée au pouvoir
de l'administration
hayden ne devrait pas changer les
éléments font de la relation sino mais
qu est-ce que demain il ya un risque de
conflit militaire entre la chine et les
états unis alors il ne peut jamais être
exclu mais il est pour l'instant
extrêmement peu probable non seulement
car aucun des deux pays n'a intérêt à ce
conflit mais aussi car s'il ya un
incident militaire il y à l'heure
allemande et canaux de communication qui
peuvent permettre d'éviter une escalade
et donc d'éviter un conflit militaire
ouvert la pression militaire sur la
chine
la pression militaire de la chine pardon
sur taïwan continue de se renforcer
et ça évidemment c'est un risque
important des incidents qui si cet
incident n'est pas bien gérée peut
déboucher une finition